it's time for seeing an unseen segment
where we explore the cultural stories of
the day and for that we turn to fox news
contributor raymond arroyo
matt raymond this segment
is all about the dangers of putting on a
show
yes starting with the white house
correspondents dinner laura the annual
weekend of journalistic
self-congratulation jammed with
politicians and assorted celebrities but
it turns out trevor noah's comments
proved prophetic listen it is my great
honor to be speaking tonight at the
nation's most distinguished super
spreader events
no for real people what are we doing
here let's be honest what are we doing
like did none of you learn anything from
the gridiron dinner nothing huh like do
you read any of your own newspapers
apparently not laura cnn is reporting
that multiple correspondent dinner
attendees from various news operations
are testing positive for what the daily
mail describes as a super spreader by
the way this is with same-day testing
and multiple boosters needed for
admission but the uh the tedious affair
revealed more than the participants i
think imagine they attempted to pass
this nerd prom off as the oscars on the
potomac
from washington it's the white house
correspondents dinner with special
appearances by gail king
cecilia vega yamiche alcindor
the president of the united states
laura you can't make this stuff up over
at cnn they convened what appeared to be
the entire u.n security council to sell
this thing complete with a red carpet
reporter what are they wearing i saw
kim kardashian pete davidson
caitlyn jenner was here as well if
you're a fan of succession
there was one of the i'm flanking out
jerry jerry from succession
does anyone believe that the people
trying to afford gas and put food on the
table care if jerry from succession is
dining with these pampered dc
journalists and politicos i mean all of
whom by the way failed people in various
ways they suppressed stories they didn't
like they spent like drunken kardashians
and now we've entered a recession so why
are they congratulating each other lord
well all i know is that they were really
upset always when a bunch of people
gathered in a house of worship or at an
sec football game or right now but i
have we entered a different stage of the
pandemic is it the end of the pandemic
or are we just getting going raymond
it's always hard to figure it out well
typical of a bad awards show this white
house correspondents dinner had a lame
sketch with
james corden and the president and the
president appeared to have no idea who
james corden was biden also had no idea
that he was reading a joke from the
teleprompter
just imagine if my predecessor came to
this dinner
this year
now that
would really have been a real coup if
that occurred
a little tough huh
i'm so sad so sad
trevor noah barely uh laid a hand on
biden raymond i mean we watched the
clips though he did make this important
observation
you guys have integrity you would never
allow personal connections to affect
your ability to be good journalists
isn't that right chris cuomo where is
chris by the way is he
is he here
he was probably watching at jeff
zucker's house laura uh there are a few
things trevor got wrong however
including who was in attendance he
repeatedly claimed governor ron desantis
was there he called desantis out the
next day desantis held a press
conference
i would never attend that i have no
interest in that so here they are saying
how important they are that they're
somehow these paragons of truth and yet
there they are lying about something
that is readily
verifiable
and again this is why their ratings and
trustworthiness among the public law is
at an all-time low among 46 countries we
are the lowest in media trust oh and
trevor noah recognized you from the
podium as well laura
how about that [ __ ] primetime lineup
huh tucker carlson sean hannity laura
ingram oh laura ingram wow
okay someone named matt gertz from media
matters tweeted laura ingram was at the
white house correspondents dinner so
tell me laura how was the food did you
see pete davidson what happened
well i i was with you and all of our
friends at the new orleans jazz fest
there we are
we had all of our tests yeah i was
actually i think that was at the who in
the who performed roger daltrey pete
townsend and
um you know ringo starr son on the drums
uh that was actually a fun time that
whole day yeah
unlike this correspondent
no
and laura as long as we're talking about
dangers of putting on a show i'm sure
ukraine now feels very safe and secure
since the united states has sent its
best and brightest to support zielinski
[Music]
poor nancy pelosi can't walk straight
laura but she's going to strike fear in
the hearts of the russians i don't think
so but i'm certain putin's going to pull
back those tanks after seeing that adam
schiff is also on the scene
ukraine's inflation rate just rose by at
least two points and its borders are
probably 50 percent more porous now well
i think they should have switched
costumes uh zielinski should have worn
the pantsuit and nancy should have worn
the fatigues that would have gotten my
attention but will uh what nancy said to
the ukrainian president i should give
everybody some pause
raymond your fight is a fight for
everyone
and so our commitment is to be there for
you until the fight is done
until the fight has shot to make that
kind of commitment she the
commander-in-chief if they voted on a
war war resolution declared war in
congress i think they haven't done that
in what
seventy-five seven years until the end
all right raymond um so sad we missed
the white house correspondents dinner
not
thomas was a lot better irma jose
feliciano and the who and everybody else
raymond indeed great to see you and
while the left hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else